professor of statistics at stanford
and has worked on many different
interesting applications of statistics
and data
today's talk is about problems in
manifold sampling for data science
applications
susan can you hear us
susan how about now can you hear us
can you hear us
susan
okay i took off the headphones i still
can't
can you say something
can you hear us now
hello can you hear us now yes i can
okay great we will
we'll
start again
our last speaker today is
susan holmes a professor of statistics
at stanford
over her career she's worked with data
from many different domains
using statistics and
data science in many different forms and
today's talk is about manifold sampling
for data science applications
okay thank you sorry about the technical
and i hope you can hear me and let me
know if you can't
um i'm happy to be an outsider and talk
to you about why we care about all the
wonderful ways that you have devised to
do something and i'm going to talk a
little bit about
what we do in statistics and applied
work
there's a paper about some of this work
which has already appeared 10 years ago
with mehdad shashahani and perseudia
konis which is called sampling on a
manifold
and there's other work about the
manifold learning which is work with the
phd students
again that i'll also talk about
motivations
for wanting to sample from manifolds
come from topological data analysis and
their verification using generative
models and we use
sampling also for goodness of fit and
something which is called name and
smooth test which involves sampling from
manifolds from non-uniform distributions
i'm particularly interested in the field
of biology we use a lot of methods for
doing manifold learning and that brought
up several
problems that we have
in particular there are open problems in
identifiability that i'd like to have
time to talk about at the end
so first of all
the first part is about how do we go
from discrete data to trying to infer
actually an underlying continuous
topological support
and the typical example is uh that are
the method developed both at duke and at
stanford by topologists computational
topologists to use um estimates of betty
numbers
and this is done for instance you have
points random
say uniformly on a on a taurus and then
you blow up those points a little bit
and we
construct what's called persistence
diagrams and from the persistence
diagram you can infer what the betting
number of the shape from which your
sampling
is
so in that protocol
the way we go from the disk discrete
points
um is that we
make little balls of radius epsilon
around them and then as they connect up
we have numbers of connected components
which are different and you can compute
what the whole the number of holes
and the way in which the simplicities
are assembled
and in order to verify this we were
doing work with gunner carlson at
stanford at the time
the first thing they wanted to do was
take a torus and generate a random
points on a manifold
so you take finite samples of points on
the manifold that you want to try and
find the shape of
and you use some kind of computational
topology tool to compute the persistence
diagrams and then you evaluate the error
rate that is you've computed the better
betty numbers and you want to know how
much you're off
so the first thing that where that they
did was to say okay here's the equation
as we see it in some sense of the torus
and we're going to take those equations
and say we generate a random between 0
and 2 pi theta and psi and then we're
going to
embed that in 3d
and
if we do this
we get
points like this
when they're projected down
this is the what the projections look
like though it's sort of supposed to be
like sesame seeds on a bagel
and uh you hope that they're uniformly
distributed on the on the manifold as it
turns out in fact and you'll notice this
this naive method
over samples or
creates too many points when there's
high curvature
and so that's a problem
and this naive wrong method uses the
embedding and writes down in some sense
the area measure
but
you thicken you take the surface and you
thicken it by say
epsilon so you get something which is
three
and then you compute you know the usual
volume and that's why they use the
standard
embedding of the taurus
so this area measure is normalized
in some sense in the wrong way to give
the uniform distribution and it's
counter-intuitive so many mathematicians
when they're trying to generate uniform
data on the manifold
um
they get it wrong and so the the sample
points not being uniform we came back to
that and studied it and tried to say
what is the way in which you're going to
make a transformation so that you get
actually the uniform measure on your
manifold
so you want to calibrate
your algorithms but since you want the
uniform distribution you first have to
generate uniformly
we also do this in statistics for
goodness of fit tests and so
fischer had a procedure in which you
define the goodness of fit where you
take the observed data and you have
sufficient statistics
from that data and you're going to
compute many
um different
instances of points generated on a
manifold with that given sufficient
statistic and in particular you know it
might be a gamma distribution or
something from an exponential family
and we want to find out whether your
statistic on the observed data is
typical
um given the sufficient statistic
so testing on the for the gamma
distribution the sufficient statistic is
the sum and the product of the x's of
the observations
and this is a compact n minus two
dimensional sub manifold in rn
and we want to sample from m
and we want to test random variables
independently drawn from a gamma density
with given
s and p
so again this is a case where we want to
sample from
a manifold but in this case we don't
want to sample uniformly from it we have
a gamma density
so the conditional distribution is what
we're interested in and it has a simple
density with respect to our area measure
and this is sort of the
typical bread and butter statistical
goodness of fit test that one would want
to do but it also applies to constraints
in physics and chemistry problems in
computational chemistry for instance you
have configurations
with given inter
atomic distances and certain angles are
fixed as well and then you want to look
at generate all samples which verify
those conditions
and so that's again something from a
manifold
with given constraints and it might not
necessarily that you want to do
uniformly
so we're going to study uh
generalizations and the way we go about
it is we are going to embed the m the
sum manifold in rn
and we have a density um
f
and
we're going to look at mostly we'll use
hausdorff we'll use the m-dimensional
area measure on m
and we draw samples from a normalized
version of f
so that it's a probability distribution
the only other
place where we found good literature on
this was an old book by chor
and it's a different development in that
we're using embeddings and they he went
directly with romanian manifolds and
smooth functions so it's slightly
different
development
so the tools we use come from geometric
measure theory and in all of our
applications um
what we're interested in are pieces of
manifolds
in general they often have
corners for reasons of constraints which
occur
um
given that the in this case given the
sufficient statistics so this is the
type of manifold that mom one might get
um
and then we'll be using well lipschitz
functions are very important and we'll
suppose that um
the sets we're interested are m
both that makes everything work properly
and we'll be considering that lambda n
is our le beg measure and
we
define and we use all the time the
housedolf measure
as it's defined um on the rectifiable
sets and
that have coverings
and so this is um sort of standard in
geometric measure theory the constant
you see the number you know the
here we have alpha m and that's um the
volume of the unit ball um that comes in
so
firm
closed sets um the federer shows that
you can write this what i said at the
beginning the way we define the area
measure as the limit when epsilon goes
smooth it becomes small that is you find
you fatten by epsilon and then you make
it decrease in size
of the le beg measure
so that's the justification in some
sense of the hair stick that we had at
the beginning
um and that's usually how people think
about
computing
area measure on on a manifold
one of the most important components and
in some sense it's a generalization of
the change of variables is that we're
going to use the jacobian
for computing the area measure and
this is just the standard jacobian that
is if you have a function which is um
differentiable from rm into rn
and
you define the
the the linear map
of differentiation um this limit here
and
the lipschitz function uh
ellipsis function is going to be
differentiable
almost everywhere with regards to lambda
and the bag
and for that we have also
the matrix which is given by the partial
derivatives which
is the usual
um notation that we have the d i f j so
that's the differential
the
differentiation
and the k dimensional jacobian is
the maximum k dimensional volume of the
image on the df of x
and in general it's defined with regards
to the norm
of a d f of x depending on what the rank
is um and of course if the
if the ranking
is if it's degenerate then you know this
is zero but in general it's the absolute
value of the determinant of df of x
now the area formula uses that and we
have this transformation um of measures
like a change of variables
and we can write that the integral with
regards to the
with of g of f of x is equal to g of y
and here we just have the number of
times that f of x is given to a
a given value and if the function is one
to one this disappears and that will
just have g of y and haustoff measure on
the right so this is a standard in
geometric measure theory but it's
actually the basis of what we do
when we do the algorithms for generating
uniform according to the right measure
so
um the example of the curve taurus let's
come back to the example that was wrong
and see what was missing well it was the
change of variable
formula which is necessary and so here
we have the determinant
and we have this extra element r squares
and then capital r plus little r cosine
theta squared and so that is going to
come in into the algorithm when we
change the measure so that's why in some
sense
close to the in the middle of the circle
there are too many points because
there wasn't the right weighting
when we have the example of the gamma
distribution with given sum and product
these constraints again
can be written out
we can
decide to take a function where we're
going to fix the first two coordinates
and then the other coordinates um
everything will be dependent on the sum
and the product and so we can write out
that if uh the sum of the
all the values except the first two is s
and it's s minus t and the product is p
we can write out that the f x 1 and x 2
have to be of this form
and we can parametrize m in two
different ways depending on how we
constrain the order of x 1 and x 2 but
let's say we look at m plus
and we can define u um um
this as our manifold with the conditions
and we have the change of variables that
we can write out so f1 and f2 are our
functions
and then we can write out what the
differential is and what the jacobian
will be and the jacobian can be written
out quite simply in this case because
we're left with a
just a two by two uh matrix to write
so the density of the m minus two
dimensional area is actually computable
and we can do it um just taking this
determinant of the jacobian so these are
not using
randomness right now they're using
formulas to change of measure to make to
take into account the constraints and
the fact that we're sitting on a
manifold
and those are sort of you know caveats
about it um with the measure zero now we
can use the
convention we want to do the conditional
distribution on the manifold with a
gamma distribution and for that we can
use uh the coe area formula which is uh
stronger than the area formula which
allows us to compute
the conditional distribution
and this gives us a way of solving in
some sense fischer's
test
and so we have a definition i won't go
into too many of the details but this is
the main proposition and the proof is in
the paper
but uh we have both the marginal density
um and we can write out in some sense
what our conditional distribution is
going to be and compute it from our
differential from a jacobian
now once we've written that out we
actually have to do a little bit of
simulation so in the case of the curved
torus i told you we have a change we
have a density we have this change
from the uniform we have to add this
extra term in
and we can use a random number generator
this in this case it's very simple we
don't even need mcmc
and in if we write out the formula we
can do rejection sampling because we
have exactly the area under the curve
and this is what the rejection sampling
proportional to this value this is what
it gives you and the result of the
points this is the taurus it has quite a
large um quite a small hole in this
case but this is different projections
of the points um from the 3d and what
you see is these are all uniform and you
don't have this build up along area the
places where there's high curvature
in the case of the summon product
we have to do sampling from the area
measure we do have this change um a
variable but we have to actually do some
um
once we have the formula with the
constraints we do give sampling
but we have to
keep a certain number of the coordinates
fixed we can't just um fix two at a time
but we can
we can use um
a modification of
gibbs sampling that works um in this
case
so
if you wanted to naively say i want to
sample on a manifold with a markov chain
and we've seen this in a couple of
papers
there there is a intuitive method for
doing it wrong
which is that if you have the manifold
and it's you know compact embedded
manifold and you want to sample from the
area measure you might say okay i'm
going to take a neighborhood of my point
and i'll restrict myself to that
neighborhood
and you'll sample from the area measure
restricted to that
and you could pick a point
in your neighborhood restricted to that
measure and in fact
although locally you're using the right
area measure globally this doesn't give
you the right answer
and maybe the best way of seeing that is
to think about it not on a manifold but
think about the equivalent problem but
on a graph
and so suppose that you have the
discrete case and you have a finite
connected graph with a
probability measure in here we want to
probably measure which isn't uniform
suppose pi of x isn't uniform
and at each point we have a neighborhood
and we'll suppose that if x is in the if
x is in the neighborhood of y y will be
in the neighborhood of x and for
instance you could have graph distance
um
fixed for your neighborhood say
a ball of radius r in graph distance and
you take the markov chains that such
that you choose y in your neighborhood
so at a distance of say two and with a
probability pi restricted to that
neighborhood so here this is the
kernel would be i go from x to y with
probability pi over y
over pi of the neighborhood
of the measure
and the this chain is reversible
and its reversing measure is
pi of n of x
pi of x over z
so at point x we have this is our
measure and it's not equal to pi
unless
pi of n x is a constant so we don't get
pi as our um
stationary distribution using this
um and so that is not um that wasn't the
goal so you see that there's a problem
when you take into account just locally
your conditioning
it will depend
if you have very different neighborhood
sizes then um you'll get the wrong
measure
so this was done and this um
people have analyzed the
this method um of
creating a chain
and
in the case of compact romanian
manifolds in lubo and michelle
and they're actually when they started
off they they made that mistake they
weren't getting the right stationary
distribution
if you do
if you are if your manifold is just a
curve so
um in and then you're just trying to
generate
on a curve and you're using arc length
for your um area measure
this can be considered constant if your
r if the ball is is small enough
and there's a theorem um you that we use
a lot in statistics called the volumes
of tubes formula which
enables you to say that the the volumes
are going to stay constant and so
but this won't be true if um you have a
higher dimensional manifold so not
through just the arc length but if
you're in higher dimensional manifold
and you don't have a constant curvature
for instance gaussian curvature
so the in general it's the curvature
which is going to pose the problem
and we'll see later on that
curvature poses
also problems when we want to go back um
to manifolds from data so curvature's
the problem maybe i won't take um since
this is a shorter talk i won't take the
time right now to go through it's in the
paper but we did other types of tests
name and smooth tests are a good example
of using um
um it's it's trying to use the inverse
cdf to bring things back to uniform but
with a specific exponential family it's
quite a nice test and it gives rise to
another set of manifolds but i i don't
have really the time to go through the
details of that
so i won't do that but i want to talk
about manifold learning and the open
problems
so
i just talked to you about cases where
we had manifolds which were given to us
and either we were doing generative
models or we were trying to do testing
but we had the equations of the manifold
now uh what often happens for me is that
i have data which are very high
dimensional biological data and we try
to learn if there's an underlying lower
dimensional manifold
which could explain
some of the variability in the data in
particular we look for things like
landscapes fitness landscapes or energy
landscapes and we're trying to learn a
natural parameterization in that case
this occurs in very simple cases so with
um president kunst and sharad goel we
looked at
high dimensional voting data political
science and in that type of data we got
two horseshoes if you use kernel
multi-dimensional scaling or a kind of
local manifold learning method
you get very clear arcs two arcs
the reason
our analysis worked so well in this case
and we were able to do it actually all
the way through to the spectral analysis
was that
the sampling along the two manifolds
here was practically uniform so we had
uniform sampling along the manifolds
in general that doesn't happen so in the
type of data that i analyze i do the
microbiome
and
in this case these are samples that are
taken from the ocean at different depths
and the gray points are actually the
data points as they lie in
two-dimensional
dimension reduction
factors
and these are the projections and so
they're the projections along a
one-dimensional manifold which is in
this case a gradient and we were able to
understand this gradient because it was
the depth at which the samples were
taken
and so here we have
the depths and so this is the deepest
and this is the shallowest
the samples and of course the depth
explain the composition in terms of
bacteria because the depth influences
the amount of oxygen and the amount of
light that the bacteria have so it's
very easy to explain and
what we saw was that the uncertainty
with which we know parts of the manifold
are very unequal
and so you have
[Music]
parts of the manifold which seem
rather empty
and so you have non-uniform
points along the manifold and this poses
problems both of uncertainty
quantification but also
being sure actually that this was
enough information to infer the manifold
form
so
unfortunately real data do not sit
uniformly distributed on a manifold
so when we're trying to do manifold
learning
uh we
want to do transformations
so that
we have
changed the metric to account for
the difference in distributions and this
i'm not going to give you all the
details of how we did this but this work
that we did with len
involved making an inverse variance
stabilizing transformation locally so we
make the data
first of all homoscedastic which is
already
one step towards being uniform and then
at least
more uniform and this is done by
changing the metric
so you can change the metric so the
points which look as if they're denser
um are spread out by spreading out if
you imagine that the manifold is elastic
you spread out the the
the manifold that way and so you want to
use a romanian metric on the manifold
which is locally different and which
takes into account the variance
so the best data
for manifold learning are uniform and we
have transformations of the data where
we try to make the data more
more uniform
and
while
when we know the dimension of the
underlying manifold so in the case of
the gradient for the tara ocean data we
had a good reason to believe that the
dimension that it was one dimensional
manifold that it was a curve a gradient
but when you don't have the underlying
dimension then it becomes much more
difficult
there's an identifiability problem which
remains which i think is an interesting
open problem which um to my mind some of
the people who do optimal transform
transport uh would be able to solve and
i'd like to say that problem and maybe
um you can ask questions about it but um
that i'll explain it to you a little bit
intuitively it's a it's a geometric
problem
that is that if you're not told what the
manifold is on what even the dimension
of the manifold is and that you know
that your data are
very non-uniform that is they also have
clusters when you start doing manifold
learning many of the algorithms the
first step that they do is say i start
off with
20 000 gene expressions so i have 20 000
features the first move that is made is
to do a principal component analysis or
dimension reduction say down to 20
dimensions
to
reduce the noise
and in those 20 dimensions then people
do
t-sne or umab or methods that are
considered to be manifold learning but
in that first
[Music]
projecting down the data there's a lot
of clumping of
the data which appears
so if you looked in
say the projection in the first two
dimensions you might see something like
this and what this is supposed to
represent the scale
the light shows
higher much higher density points
and so you have clusters you might have
clusters of points which seem to occur
in these areas
and the question that comes up and this
might you know be explained by if it was
simple um the this type of configuration
of points and these clustering here you
have clusters
of points which are lighter and you see
that
but in fact if in your original data the
data weren't linear but they're lying
close to a very high dimensional
manifold we would see them um say that
instead of being clustered the points
lied
on a grid or practically on the grid
uniformly distributed on a manifold
and that they were projected down then
you would see the same thing
and so we don't know
whether the clustering here is due to
the fact that there's actual
big there are actually big changes in
the density or that there are big
changes in the curvature
so the
the way about that
has been for us to try to
even things out to make things more
uniform but that's been very difficult
um to wrap our heads around and there's
a there's a very interesting sort of
theoretical computer science problem
about the
identifiability of the changings of the
change of density
um the change of curvature and as i
showed you you know the curvature
changes the way you get the uniform
distribution and you have to take into
it into account using the jacobian but
that um comes into machine learning as
well
okay so i i'm you know said the problem
that i'm interested in um you know
asking you in some sense and for the
references um the
references
the main um
reference that we
you know used um is the paper with madab
shazahani which appeared
and there are other papers here um by
gunner carlson on doing tda
and the book that we used is federer's
geometric measure theory
so thank you thank you for inviting me
thank you
we have time for questions
are there any questions i took down the
yes can you hear me
yes i can
uh sure so i uh know a couple things
about optimal transport
uh and
just thinking about your open problem
um
my understanding of the optimal
transport literature is that rather than
solving your problem it it somehow
dissolves it
so
uh in in the sense that
uh in the
uh literature on curvature dimension
bounds in optimal transport
uh there is actual actually no clear
distinguished distinguishing between the
curvature and the density so what is
done is that rather than working with a
manifold you work with a manifold with a
stipulated reference measure
and then and then you define a new
curvature tensor which has the
reference measure somehow embedded in it
so this thing is called the backre-emery
curvature tensor and then all of the
curvature data on the manifold is
written with the
not necessarily uniform reference
measure somehow encoded inside the
curvature data so i have no idea how
that would actually whether that would
be of any use to you
but somehow the
the the problem of non-identifiability
is recognized in the optimal transport
literature and they have just sort of
accepted that this is how life is so i
don't know
if that's informative but you know
no no i mean i think it does solve the
problem for instance in biology there
are things which you know you can never
deconvolve and so you just have to talk
about them together
you know the mutation rate and uh along
a tree and the time and the so so so
there are some things which you'll never
be able to
identify
and
i guess it does solve the problem but
from a practical viewpoint um in what we
do
i guess i would i would hope that you
could separate
so maybe that you could make
transformations that take out some of
the curvature
um
yeah i'm looking for trans ways of
transforming the data right so
uh in in
so i get hold of the underlying
manifold as if it were uniform so an
equivalent uniform is what i'm looking
for
uh
but but that but that's good although
what you're telling me and i know
dominique backseat pretty well and i
know i can't read anything he writes
so
uh it might be
there might be a more concrete uh place
to read about that
there are several theoretical computer
scientists in the audience just to make
sure we understand your last problem
um so you have data that's coming from
some unknown manifold and you'd like to
you don't know its curvature
uh what you may know nothing about the
manifold you see a projection
and
it looks dense in some places but that
could be
so so do you really know have no
assumptions on the manifold at all
well no usually no no that's not fair
usually you you believe it's quite low
dimensional so it might be that you
believe that it's two or three
dimensions but you don't know whether
it's two or three
or four but it's quite low-dimensional
um
and
but
um
but one thing you are sure is that your
data are not uniformly distributed on
that manifold
but what about some kind of uh
symmetry or or uh
uh
property of the of the curvature itself
so
so
you do you know for example if it's
okay i see
no usually usually that part is just all
the data i mean
sometimes the only the best we can do
is like what we do in what's called
response surface design is to say
we know this is going to be this is more
highly curved we need more data you
always need more data where it's more
highly curved
and so um so
it it tells you that you need more data
in the places which are highly equipped
in some sense so that you can spread out
so can you ask for more data in specific
places do you get to go back and ask
that's what i do yes
yes that's what we do because you can't
you usually can't answer the uh you
can't answer the question in one go
right you have to generate a hypothesis
and then go back and test it right
but
yeah
hi um thank you very much for a great
talk um i'm just wondering um it's
probably a very naive question uh but uh
um have you
have you thought about something um from
a manifold with non-uniform
distributions and and under what
circumstances would you call the
distribution uni model
oh
[Music]
so
we don't know i mean unimodal means you
know just that there's one maximum
uh
in
in the density would mean for instance
that you wouldn't have clustering
uh
that you would have that you believe
that it comes from a homogeneous
population
but um the
in general when you're sampling from a
manifold
you d you ne you never know that they're
you know it's it's very non-uniform the
sampling procedure but it's hidden to
you
so there are very strong biases um uh to
parts of the manifold
but that that that part um
you don't know until sort of the second
or third time around as i say we collect
more data and then we go back
um but it's definitely one of the big
challenges that um we we never can
suppose uniformity
and well unimodality you know they
they
it's not
for high dimensions it's usually
clustered in different ways so it
doesn't have just one clean um
population
it's mixtures so in some sense we have
mixtures so
that's the classic clarification
question about the identifiability issue
so it seems like if you project to a
linear subspace
like what can be confused with density
is actually like if for example if you
take a vinylmatic curve the curve if the
curve has a like a large angle with the
linear subspace for example it's near
orthogonal then it projects as if it was
large density so that you cannot
distinguish but it seems like this is
like a first order derivative but
curator is like a second order
derivative
yeah so
so it's so if that so so that's the
question you are talking about it's it's
actually about the large angle
stuff yes
yes
and i i try to illustrate what what goes
on just by doing the taurus to show how
the curvature modifies in some sense the
density that you get naturally
i don't know whether that was so helpful
but um it's definitely the case that
that's what that's our intuition and of
course all we can do is
negative experiments where we show that
we can identify that is you can generate
data that look exactly the same
by either taking a very curved surface
and doing it on almost a grid
or you can just take a flat
surface and then cluster the points and
you can get two indistinguishable
distributions and so i wondered whether
um and i think you probably solved it
by saying that the optimal transport
people know that you can't do it so
then we have to then we have to
do a step-by-step procedure for
deconvolving but
any more questions
now let's thank uh susan again
thank you for having me
meet you back here tomorrow 9 30.